thank you
oh
okay
okay
you
uh
foreign
thank you
let's go
uh
thank you
[Music]
thank you
so
hear me
is
hi everyone
thanks for your patience a little
delayed today but for good reason
so i have a couple of items at the top
as you know tonight the president
will deliver his first prime time
address to the american people
at 8 p.m today marks the one year
anniversary of the shutdown due to coven
19 and the president will speak
directly to the american people about
the sacrifices made
from the more than 500 000 lives lost to
the millions of people who are lost have
lost their jobs
and even millions more who have been
impacted by the pandemic
he'll provide an update on the work of
his team to address the greatest
operational challenge the country has
faced
and the work his team has done to
rapidly increase the number of
vaccinations
vaccines vaccination vaccinators and
vaccination sites
and he will lay out the next steps he
will take to get the pandemic
under control even while he is focused
on getting the american rescue plan
across the finish line
he has been reviewing drafts of the
speech last week he was
and of course through the course of this
week and making line edits
uh he's been uh providing line edits in
order to ensure that he is striking the
right tone
and providing the right level of clarity
uh as he
prepares to address the country this
evening
he plans to provide a clear outline of
his approach
level with the american people about
what is required of them
but also provide a sense of hope of what
is possible
i wanted to provide a little bit more on
upcoming travel
as you of of all of our principles as we
as we worked as we prepare
to go out and engage with the american
people about what is in
the rescue plan as you know next week
the president the vice president the
first lady and the second gentleman will
be traveling across the country to kick
off the help is here tour
and amplify the american rescue plan on
monday the first lady will travel to
burlington new jersey the vice president
and second general will travel to
las vegas nevada on tuesday the
president will travel to delaware county
pennsylvania
as you already are aware the vice
president and second second gentleman
will travel to denver colorado
on wednesday the second gentleman will
travel to travel to albuquerque new
mexico
and on friday the president and the vice
president will travel to atlanta georgia
during their trips they will discuss the
benefits of the american
rescue plan for working families and
they will engage
with people at each of these stops about
how
the american people can benefit from the
components of the package
uh moving forward so they will talk
about the 1400
checks that more than that 158.5
million american households can expect
uh and which uh
and many who will start receiving them
soon he will talk about the historic
expansion of the child tax credit
he will talk about extending they will
talk about extending unemployment
insurance for around 11 million
americans
the tens of billions of dollars in
rental and homeowners resistance that is
a part of this package the expansion of
the earned income
tax credit which will go to 17 million
workers
and the components of the package that
significantly reduce
health insurance premiums for millions
of american families
and of course the fact that the bill
will lift 11 million people out of
poverty
and cut child poverty in half and
they're eager to get out there on the
road
and i have one more exciting
implementation update for all of you
since the treasury department department
of treasury and the irs are working hard
to get relief payments out the door
as fast as possible to the american
people people can expect to
start seeing direct posits hit their
bank accounts as early as this weekend
this is of course just the first wave
but
some people will start some people in
the country will start seeing those
in those direct deposits in their bank
accounts this weekend
and payments to eligible americans will
continue
throughout the course of the next
several weeks
so with that jonathan why don't you kick
us off thank you jen
uh tomorrow the chief of staff tweeted
uh there'll still be a celebration in
terms of this bill signing congressional
leaders would be
attending can you tell us who will be
there and if any
republicans who none of them voted for
this bill would be invited
so the uh the celebration tomorrow uh
will be a bipartisan i mean a bicameral
excuse me
uh event um but it will not be
bipartisan it will be
it will include leadership uh and we are
still finalizing the list of attendees
but we hope to get that to you as soon
as it's finalized
can you walk us through as part of the
help this year tour uh
decisions behind the locations for the
travel
next week in particular the president's
two stops why
why pennsylvania and why georgia well
this is just the beginning of the
president
and the firstly and the first ladies and
the vice presidents and the second
gentleman's
uh travel and they will of course do
some travel in addition to
next week but it was important to the
president to visit
not just blue states uh uh and but also
red states purple states you will see
that reflected as we
continue to announce uh travel and trips
that he will take in the coming weeks
obviously these are um two places where
he he of course talked about the
importance of
delivering on the promise of getting
every american the two thousand dollar
checks when he campaigned in georgia in
december
so that's a place where that uh message
really resonated of course with the
people of the state
and where it was amplified to the public
uh but you know it's a place also close
to his heart but this is just the
beginning of the travel i wouldn't
over read into it other than uh he
he's looking to uh having he's looking
forward to having uh
the senior members of the the principals
from the administration out across the
country fanning out across the country
which is exactly what they're doing
and one more on a uh on a different
topic the trial of
minneapolis police officer derek
chubbing has begun uh in corrections the
death of george
floyd has the president been briefed on
the development so far
and he condemned the death certainly
when it happened
does he believe the police officer
should be convicted of verdict
well the the president obviously doesn't
weigh into um
he's not going to weigh into an ongoing
uh judicial
uh or a legal case um he's watching it
closely
as are many members of the
administration uh
as you know he himself encouraged the
house to pass the
bill uh that um and he is
very pleased that it did and policing
reform in broadly speaking is an issue
that he believes is urgent and one that
he is committed to
working with leaders in congress and
also taking steps as he can take
on his own uh to address but you know he
has spoken about
uh he spoke about the trial and of
course the the death of george
george floyd in personal terms and that
is a reflection of how
he continues to feel as he watches uh
the events unfold
with the trial it affected him
personally um it redoubled his
commitment to addre
advancing racial justice that's why he
signed an executive order on racial
equity on his sixth day one of the
reasons why he signed
an executive order on racial equity on
his sixth day in office and of course he
will be
watching it closely as many people in
the country will
roger be done a follow-up on some of the
vaccine news from yesterday and the
president said
that one reason he wanted to have
another 100 million
doses of the johnson johnson vaccine in
the
cupboards as it were is to be prepared
um if everyone is vaccinated by the end
of may
or at least able to be what are you
preparing for
what might happen that the u.s would
need an additional 100 million
shots for well we talked about this a
little bit yesterday but the reason why
uh one of the reasons why we ordered uh
the additional hundred million doses is
because we don't yet know
uh what a vaccine is most effective with
children those
tests that testing is still happening
with the fda as we speak as you noted he
wants to be
over prepared and oversupplied we're
still looking at the impact
of variants these this order of dosage
can
doses can also be used for booster shots
which is something that's also
under uh review by the fda so
he's just preparing to ensure we are
ready for every contingency
uh here in the united states uh of
course we want to be a part of the
um effort around the world to vaccinate
people around the world in a range of
countries that's why we've
provided two billion dollars to kovacs
with another two billion dollars
committed we are the largest funder of
global health in the world
um and we've invested over 150 billion
in global health activities since
2000 we've re-engaged on day one with
the world health organization
and we're continuing to engage he is
personally and many levels of our
administration are engaged personally
with their counterparts about addressing
this pandemic
globally but his first priority and
focus is on
ensuring that the american people are
vaccinated and
once we're at that point we will have a
discussion about what's next
my understanding is the president
directed this to happen yesterday but
the deal was not
with jnj isn't yet in place when do you
expect the deal to be made
soon i can get you an update i can check
with our team and see if there's uh
what the final details are but we
certainly anticipate and expect the deal
to fully move forward
just one other vaccine question related
to a story that my colleagues did from
europe has the u.s told the european
union
not to expect deliveries of copa 19
vaccines from astrazeneca
that are made in this country well
i would say first we have conveyed
privately what we've conveyed publicly
which is that our focus is on
ensuring the american people are
vaccinated and
of course any company can work with any
country around the world
on the purchase of vaccine supply and
certainly that wouldn't be something the
us government would be directly engaged
with but
in terms of the supply we have purchased
our first focus our primary focus is on
vaccinating the american people that's
what we convey publicly and privately as
well
yeah you said that a lot but have there
been any specific
indications or conversations with the eu
saying
don't expect this to come from our
country at least until
the rest of the effects of this
population is vaccinated we have pretty
we have said that
we have said publicly exactly what i've
conveyed which is what i'm conveying is
we convey the same thing
privately of course any country can
purchase vaccines from
uh these manufacturers um directly
uh good thank you uh mexico's president
andres manuel lopez obrador said the
people coming into the u.s right now
see by then president biden as the
migrant
president does the white house take that
as a compliment
migrant give me a little more context
well he said uh they see him as the
migrant president and so many feel
but so many feel they're going to reach
the united states
we need to work together to regulate the
flow because this business can't be
tackled from one day to the next
well first it's mexico will have to be
is an important partner in ensuring
we're addressing
the flow of migrants from central
america
through mexico many to the border of the
united states
we have conveyed privately and publicly
as well that
the majority of people who come to our
border will be turned away
we certainly also recognize that because
the president
and our administration has made a
decision that the way to humanely
approach immigration is to allow for
um you know uh for unaccompanied minors
to
come and be treated with humanity and
and be uh
be uh in in safe uh place uh while we're
considering
uh well we're trying to get them into a
new home into homes and sponsored homes
that uh that some more may have come to
our border and there have been
of course a a large flow of children
across the border we
recognize that but we that is that we
made a policy decision because we felt
it was the humane approach but
the facts are the vast vast majority
of people who come to our border are
turned away and the statistics
bear that out okay and then in terms of
keeping cobit out of the country does
the white house think that it's a
problem
that travelers have to show a negative
covenant test proof of a negative
covenant test when they
fly into the u.s from any foreign
country but
travelers don't need to show anything
like that when they just walk across the
border as long as they don't go
to a port of entry well i think there's
been a lot of confusion about
what's been happening at the border as
it relates to
people who are coming across and what
happens
when they come across and i know
governor abbott down in texas has
has expressed some of his concerns and
many of those have not been based in
fact
so let me go through a few of those
because i know we're all interested in
facts around here
one uh governor abbott has referred to
what's happening
at the border as open borders as us
having an open borders policy that is
absolutely
incorrect uh the border is not open the
vast majority of individuals
uh apprehended or encountered at the
border continue to be denied entry
and a return until under title 42 as
we've already mentioned
uh also he has suggested that we are not
vaccinating cbp
officers again we like to deal with
facts around here there's no higher
priority than the health and safety of
our federal workforce
and the department of homeland security
and cbp has been clear that
uh currently more than 64 000 frontline
dhs employees including members of u.s
border patrol have received
a vaccination uh so that's another just
point just
to provide full clarity uh the other
piece is
as the question about um the testing of
migrants
uh at the border uh or testing of
migrants as as they're are coming across
and we have dhs and fema have stepped in
and worked with local mayors ngos and
public health officials in texas to
implement a system to provide
coven 19 testing and as needed isolation
and quarantine for families
released from border patrol facilities
their proposal and agreement
would cover 100 percent of the expense
of the testing
isolation and quarantine but governor
abbott has decided to reject that
so there are a number there's a lot of
confusion about these issues and i just
wanted to provide a little point of
clarity here
but not asking about governor abbott
asking about president biden
in charge of the federal government why
are the feds relying on ngos
to administer these tests we've talked
to people down at the border who say
that migrants are only tested if they
show symptoms that seems like a loophole
that's not an accurate depiction uh
there is
a there's an important role that ngos
that local mayors that local officials
play
in uh and in working together and this
is a proposal
that was worked with dhs with
fema and others to help address and
ensure
that people are tested uh and governor
abbott i raised that
simply because he had raised a concern
about that and i wanted to be clear that
we've put forward a proposal so i think
the question is
why is he standing in the way of local
communities getting the funding and
support they need to help with testing
isolation and quarantining efforts but
again just a question about fine
administration policy
covenant is kobe coleman at the dulles
airport customs is the same as covid
in a border town so i'm curious why it
is that it's enforced for people flying
in from other countries
but it is not a requirement by the
federal government
to test or to prove a negative test
anywhere along the border except at a
port of entries well again
i can just describe to you what our
policies are there's more to
convey to you i'm happy to do that and
then just one quick one on uh
green jobs you guys have talked a lot
about tackling the
climate crisis while creating
good-paying jobs now the
president of the texas afl-cio has come
out to say
someone working in a refinery leaving to
go install
solar panels they're probably going to
take a 75
cut and pay is that something the
administration is aware of
i'm not sure which jobs are being
compared there here here's what i can
convey to you
the president is committed during his
presidency to
invest in uh work with labor unions with
climate activists with a range of with
the industry
to invest in good paying clean energy
jobs and he believes that unions have an
incredibly important role to play in
ensuring that those are
high paying jobs that those treat the
people who are in them with
the respect and value that they deserve
through collective bargaining rights and
a range of the benefits of union
organizing
being a part of a union obviously that
requires
additional work and investment by the
federal government working with congress
to
invest in what we see as industries of
the future oil and gas jobs are
not going away there are many industries
that are of course
continuing to function the outgoing
administration flooded the oil markets
with
cheap federal leases this will not
affect oil and gas production or jobs
for
years to come but what our objective is
is to invest in what we see as the
industries of the future where we feel
is where the jobs are going to be moving
forward and the president looks forward
to
continuing delivering on his commitment
to doing exactly that
i'm paying good paying but equal pay
high paying good paying jobs i i think
we're comparing
a little bit i'm not sure what specific
jobs you're comparing what i'm conveying
is the the commitment to ensuring that
jobs in the uh clean energy industry
will be
high-paying union jobs that's what the
president's objective and commitment is
too
um go ahead kaitlyn the white house has
said that president biden wants to look
ahead to
a return to normal in his speech tonight
but how does he do that while also
striking the balance that 1500 americans
on average are still
dying from coronavirus every single day
you're
absolutely right caitlyn that his
objective is to strike exactly that
balance and this is one of the reasons
that he has been
line i align editing this speech for the
last uh
week plus uh to ensure that he is
conveying
that he is leveling with the american
people that he is delivering on his
commitment to being truthful
about the challenges that we continue to
face what is going to be required
of the american public to get to a
return to normalcy as you conveyed
but he also wants to provide a sense of
hope and what's possible if we
abide by the guidelines if when you have
access to a vaccine you get the vaccine
uh what people can look forward to and
so he is
that is exactly the balance that he is
hoping to strike tonight so should we
expect like concrete
steps and policy changes in this speech
tonight i think you can expect uh you
know this is his first opportunity prime
time of course uh to
really speak directly the public you we
all have a conversation about a lot of
these issues
every single day most millions of
americans out there
are living their lives some of them
you know dealing with their kids in
school
getting their jobs done etc and this
will be an opportunity for many people
to really tune in and hear from him on
his plan on what his team has done to
date uh what steps they've taken
an update since he took office but also
concrete steps he wants to take moving
forward there will be some news
in the speech uh but uh it is really
about
laying out clearly uh and uh
for the for the american public what
steps he's taken what his team will do
and what is expected of them as well
and since he's just signed this bill has
he decided who is going
to oversee the implementation of it and
then on the ceremony tomorrow
you have some republican senators who
did not vote for this bill now touting
parts of it what is president biden's
response
to those republicans like senator wicker
well we
invite them to work with us on the
agenda moving forward because
clearly the bill that the president just
signed into law is something that
the american people are excited about
that uh people will benefit from as soon
as this weekend
as we conveyed and we are hopeful that
as the president talks about his build
back better agenda has more meetings
with members of congress we'll have
uh more people on board from both sides
of the aisle and regarding who's
overseeing oh you know we are as i
mentioned yesterday the president
absolutely is committed to having a
person who is running point on it i
don't have any personnel announcements
so today question on the border
the administration has refused to call
it a crisis instead of referring to it
as a challenge and saying what you call
it doesn't make a difference of how
you're responding to it but
now today there are over 3 700 children
unaccompanied microchildren
in border patrol good custody they're
spending on average over 100 hours four
days
in these facilities that are jail-like
facilities not meant for children
so how can you say that's not a crisis
well i think what uh ambassador jacobson
and
secretary uh majes were conveying and
what i've conveyed is
it doesn't matter what you call it it is
an enormous challenge
it is something that is front and center
for the president as
as we i noted yesterday uh he had what
is a regular meeting but he had a
briefing yesterday on the trip to the
border and
there are a number of uh well there are
no final policy decisions there are a
variety of
um of actions under consideration
including
identifying and assessing other licensed
facilities that can help add safe
capacity for these children
relaunching as we talked about over the
last couple of days the central american
miners program
accelerating the unification of children
with vetted families
family and sponsors steps like embedding
hhs and orr
in the earlier parts of the process so
you know the president is very focused
and very in the weeds on the operational
details here and
on on taking and and pushing his team to
take every step
uh that can be taken to address exactly
what you noted caitlyn which is the fact
that
children should not these border patrol
facilities are not made for children uh
that we should we are focused on
expediting the time they spend there
that
these hhs shelters are not meant for uh
permanently for permanent living for
anyone permanently living there that we
want to expedite
the timeline between when kids cross the
border and when they are getting to
sponsor homes so
our focus here is on uh getting to the
root of the issues
uh uh and taking actions and we don't
feel the need to
uh you know play games with what it's
called aren't those the steps that you
would take if it was a crisis that you
had on your hands
these are the policies we're taking to
address what we feel is a
vital uh human uh challenge at the
border but
uh what our responsibility here is to do
is to project and convey
what policies we're taking uh what the
president's commitment is that's exactly
what we're doing and
uh we don't see the need to put new
labels go ahead john thank you
no republicans voted for the coveted
relief package
and they argue that this is the sixth
package
and it adds to a deficit that's already
a trillion dollars this year
alone what do you say to that criticism
that ultimately
this type of a sweeping piece of
legislation will be a drag on the
economy down the line
well i would say to them uh we're in the
midst of uh twin crises
from the pandemic to an economic
downturn
that is impacting tens of millions of
people in this country people are
struggling to make ends meet
they are worried about whether their
grandparents their cousins their friends
are able to get a vaccine
and they are suffering because they're
worried about the mental health of their
kids who
aren't back in school yet and uh the
president's focus is on addressing
those crises uh and i would point a
question a question back to many
of these uh republicans as to why uh the
deficit spending wasn't as
concerning when they were giving tax
cuts to the highest income
but now it's concerning when we're
giving uh direct
checks and relief to the american people
when you look forward at
the rest of the agenda that president
biden has laid out
how do you get even moderate democrats
on board
with another big piece of legislation
for example this climate
plan that has a price tag of two
trillion dollars there's no price tag on
a plan that doesn't exist yet uh
so there well sure but he also laid out
many components of his buildback better
agenda during his campaign and we don't
we haven't made a final decision yet as
to what uh
the format the size uh what the next
proposal will be it's
uh not even something that has been
brought to him for a decision quite yet
obviously he's had a lot of discussions
and meetings to hear from republicans
and democrats but
we're just not at that point in the
process yet i know you're not going to
weigh in on the specifics of what he's
going to tackle
next but given that this was not a
bipartisan piece of legislation and
given that the president said that
unity was one of the key things he
wanted to try to accomplish
is he going to try to move forward on a
piece of legislation where he thinks he
can get
bipartisan support in other words how is
that going to factor
his decision-making process well the
president
would of course love to have bipartisan
support and there are areas
of policy making that he has talked
about quite a bit as you noted some of
them on the campaign trail including
infrastructure
modernizing our immigration system has
actually historically been a bipartisan
policy
making issue uh he had a meeting on
cancer and addressing cancer
and tackling cancer of course there are
a lot of issues that
he feels there's opportunity to work
together on
and his open his door the door to the
oval office remains
open to bipartisanship to finding ways
to certainly work together i could try
one more
time on the issue at the border
and just follow up on the comments of
the mexican president who said that the
search
and unaccompanied migrants is because
they see the president as the migrant
president
what does that say about how the
president is handling this situation
look i think the president has been
clear as
has every member of our administration
you had ambassador jacobson doing this
the other day
that the border is not open now is not
the time to come
we turn away the vast majority of people
who come
to the border the vast vast majority
these numbers are put out by
cbp and the department of homeland
security and people can see those
numbers
uh we stand by our decision and our
policy as an administration
not to send unaccompanied minors back on
the treacherous journey so
you know that is our policy because we
feel it's humane and it's moral
and we think the world sees it that way
as well the message needs to be even
clearer though yesterday ambassador
jacobson acknowledged that yes
she said in her own words you're trying
to walk and chew gum at the same time
yeah does there need to be a more
streamlined message
in order to prevent this search well she
also talked about
christian which is true in the region
we're we're we're working against
the efforts of smugglers and others who
are conveying a different message
uh one of the steps we're taking uh that
i touched on a little bit earlier is
also uh thinking of
rebuilding or going back to some of the
policies that were in place previously
uh where children could apply uh for
um uh the central american uh miners
program which was ended in 2017. we
estimate there's about
3 000 uh kids who might be eligible who
could apply
and they could apply from the region
which would mean they wouldn't make the
treacherous journey
they wouldn't be at the border working
through border patrol
uh and so we're looking for ways to uh
reduce the number of kids who are taking
this treacherous journey and then we're
also looking for ways to
expedite when kids are connected to
family members to you know
safe sponsor homes and we're looking for
ways to expedite
getting them from the border patrol
facilities
into the shelters as well so it there's
our there's uh
numbers numbers challenges here and
we're working through a lot of the
operational details and specifics but
um we stand by um you know that what we
feel is a more humane approach
to what is happening at the border and
we are looking for ways operationally to
make it more efficient to move kids
through the system more quickly
and ultimately when they get to the
point where we're there with sponsor
homes
many of them will not be able to stay
most of them they have to apply and
they're
they have to go through the process but
we still are working for ways to
expedite the system in the meantime
uh go ahead uh one follow-up on uh
jeff's question on the discussions with
the eu
well i i don't know if it's necessarily
an exploit ban but the eu
is saying the u.s request was denied
to export vaccines but specifically on
the astrazeneca one
that's not yet authorized in the u.s and
the u.s hasn't
sought authorization so why are you guys
sitting on these doses
that could be used in the eu now because
it's already authorized
there but not here well we don't we're
not city i'm not sure which doses you're
talking about that we're sitting on
there's a report out of uh
out of europe that
the us told the european union that they
cannot expect any astrazeneca
shipments anytime soon well we don't we
we don't own
some purchases we didn't purchase
astrazeneca supplies i mean so
the there's no export prohibitions and
all vaccine manufacturers in the united
states are free to export
their products while also fulfilling the
terms of their contracts with the us
government
so in any of these government
contracts with the individual companies
are there
specific export prohibitions if it's not
an export ban overall
in the in the contracts that the us
government has with these companies
well our but you're talking about
whether we're going to give our
supply to other countries right
or are you talking about whether these
country or whether these manufacturers
are going to sell
um doses to other countries
correct the second uh
whether the sorry so there again
so i'm just trying to so are you talking
about whether these companies
are allowed to sell doses of their of
their um
well i'm talking about how it's almost
like a triangle right because
these these companies have contracts
with the us government
that say you have to fulfill this
contract with us right and so is
any of that prohibiting then exports
of any of the doses produced here as i
just conveyed
there's no there's these are not export
um
prohibitions vaccine manufacturers in
the united states
are free to export their products while
also fulfilling the terms of our
contracts there are there are supply
that they are producing for the united
states but
uh they can also work with other
countries and sorry now i think
now we're on the same level so okay the
contract that you have with these
companies
are there any specific um is there a
specific
uh provision in those contracts that
would say
you cannot export until you fulfill
our contractual obligation with the u.s
government i don't have any more details
of the contracts but
obviously these companies can work with
um
other countries on selling uh
uh their products manufacturers can work
with them to with these countries
directly we have conveyed
privately what we've conveyed publicly
which is our focus
is on ensuring the american people are
receiving
the vaccine uh and that we are
vaccinating
the american public that's our first
priority but we are also engaging with
and working with the global community
to figure out how we can get the global
pandemic under control
together whether that's through
financial contributions
or through uh you know navigating with
them
how we can work together uh to address
it
but we'll continue to evaluate as more
vaccines become available in the united
states astrazeneca isn't even approved
at this point
yeah one other topic completely
different um you just said again
the president hasn't yet made a decision
on the next legislative package or what
it will be and what will be unveiled
um there's a it seems to be a little bit
of momentum
uh led by some majority leader schumer
on a package that is like a broad sort
of china countering china package
um is the white house coordinating with
the senate democrats on this are you in
touch with them and
is the president sort of actively going
to engage with this
effort with the with the proposal by
senator schumer
correct i'm certain that senator schumer
wants to
discuss it with him he's happy to
discuss it with the
with senator schumer with leader schumer
but i would expect the president's
uh agenda moving forward will reflect
the buildback better agenda that he
talked about on the campaign trail
but the order the size the timeline has
not yet been determined
go ahead thanks jen i have a couple of
foreign policy questions
okay if you're in africa but i just want
to pick up something that uh you
discussed with um earlier about the
central american minors program sure
um i just want to make sure that i
understand you correctly that you were
presenting that as
sort of like an immediate solution to
what's happening
at the border by saying that this will
take about 3 000
kids well what i don't understand is
that first of all
what's going to be processed are the
kids who were
already in the process and it was
stopped in 2017.
and then state department will uh
continue to process a new application so
that process in itself takes months no
that
they will be prioritized um with the
process was stopped as you noted in 2017
and
uh the kids who are eligible then will
be prioritized
so it's not an immediate solution to
what's happening i don't think i said
that i don't have a timeline for you but
it is what i
actually if you were listening earlier i
i gave a number of steps actually that's
one of the steps
the other steps and address some of the
things that you just raised including
the fact that we are working to find
ways to accelerate the unification
of children with vetted families and
sponsors embedding orr
and hhs in earlier parts of the process
we're identifying and assessing other
licensed facilities so
this isn't a this isn't a challenge
that's going to be addressed through one
step
but certainly the central american
miners program is a way and the reason i
talked about it is because it's a way to
help ensure that the the application
process for these kids happens
well not while they're sitting in
shelters in the united states or even
with sponsor families but when they are
still
in their home countries and they will
know before they make the journey
that they are able to come and stay in
this country and that's a pretty pivotal
step to take
thank you for clarifying that um now on
the issue
of africa and the president shared the
assessment of secretary blinken that
what's happening on the western degree
region of
ethiopia is ethnic fencing does uh
the president have any specific view on
the particular
role of prime minister avi in this
conflict and is the u.s
considering any kind of action beyond
urging
the european government to stop sending
a force yeah i got an
update on this from my team earlier so
let me just see what i have here to
update you on
so the administration has repeatedly
engaged
the ethiopian government government on
the importance of ending the violence
ensuring unhindered humanitarian access
and allowing a full independent
international investigation
into all reports of human rights abuses
as you noted
secretary of state lincoln has spoken to
the ethiopian prime minister
twice to emphasize emphasize the united
states concern about the humanitarian
and human rights crisis we're seeing
uh during his testimony yesterday he
reiterated the situation is unacceptable
and has to change
and that we're calling on the ethiopian
government to follow through on its
commitments that it's made and also at
the u.n security council
ambassador linda thomas greenfield has
reaffirmed u.s commitment to working
bilaterally
and multilaterally to help secure an end
to the violence so the president is
deeply concerned highly engaged on this
issue he recognizes that
we have very active ongoing efforts by
our diplomats to try to move this
forward to a better place including
getting humanitarian aid workers in with
full access and
of course he remains uh in touch and and
working closely with his secretary of
state
another topic still on the show on the
issue
still on ethiop ethiopia actually the
trump administration was very much
engaged in mediating the conflict
between ethiopia
egypt and sudan on the issue of the nile
dam
is the biden willing to continue
mediation process as has been requested
by ethiopia uh
sorry but sudan and egypt i would send
you to the state department they'd be
more directly involved at this stage
one more one more question okay um
western sahara also president uh trump
as you know recognized
uh sovereignty morocco sovereignty of
the western sahara region
now spain is asking for a u.n
resolution or unbroken solution spain is
a former
uh colonizer of western sahara asking
for unbroken
solution on this issue um
has the administration completed its
review
on this particular trump deal because it
does
you know deal with the overall abraham
accords policy
and what is your position as you know we
are reviewing uh all
of the many trump positions including
the abraham accords but i don't have an
update today for you on it
go ahead uh yeah i just wanted to go
back to the border
my colleagues reported yesterday that
the administration
is looking at a nasa facility in
california to help some of these
unaccompanied children
can you talk a little bit about the plan
to identify and find
space for them what sort of facilities
are you looking at
i don't have a list of facilities but i
will convey that we are
reiterate um that part of our effort and
our focus and
what we're prioritizing is identifying
and assessing
licensed facilities that can help add
safe capacity for these children
and even with the update and cdc
guidelines that we've talked about a
little bit this week that allows for
greater capacity safely at these
facilities
we still want to ensure that we have uh
facilities that are
safe licensed and prepared to house
children so that we can move them
quickly from the border patrol
the border patrol locations but i don't
have anything we're looking at a range
of sites our team is and
and i'm sure uh some will be hopefully
identified soon but i don't have
anything to preview for you beyond that
and then on the trip with prince like
with all the principles kind of
criss-crossing the theater next week
it's an interesting list of states
yeah he said purple uh at least
um i'm wondering even though that this
relief
package has no support here what have
you been hearing
what do you expect to hear from
republicans in these states do you
expect to be received by them at all
have you heard much
like republicans like local elected or
i think what we saw uh even during the
the
um effort to pass the american rescue
plan is that
there are 400 governors and mayors
across the country many of them
republican we had a republican mayor
come here and talk to you all about
how vital and important this was to his
community
and so we certainly anticipate that many
of the local elected officials who
supported the passage
who are seeing um you know funding
coming into their states to help ensure
that
cops and firefighters keep their jobs
seeing funding that's going to come in
and help reopen schools
seeing people in their communities get
checks as early as this weekend that
they will be open many of them to
engaging with the president the vice
president the first lady the second
gentleman
where there's an opportunity to talk
about the benefits and
can and communicate to their communities
about how people can access these
benefits and that's a big part of the
this um blitz around the country is
ensuring that
the american people have that
understanding and that's what uh
our uh all of our uh principles will be
conveying
can i ask another quick one sure i'm
just curious i know the president has
speech writers but
were you around him when he was working
on this speech like who were the
advisors around him that have weighed in
and pitched in ideas and helped him edit
sure look i i think um
you know the president has been doing
this a while and certainly he had
a good sense of what he wanted to convey
uh and he is someone who is
um a uh you know a um
an anti an anti-acronyms advocate
um so he wants to uh explain
things with clarity um and with
directness
uh to the american people and i will
tell you that when he goes through
speeches like this he asks questions
that
i can imagine um friends of mine and
family members of mine might ask what do
you mean by that and when you say that
how will i get access to that and that's
when he reads through the speech what
he's looking to provide
clarity on and he fully recognizes that
um that you know speaking during a prime
time address is a moment
where you have to um you know tell a
story
about uh and and recognize the um the
the the great sacrifices the american
people have been through
and speak with truth and with directness
about what is still required um but also
um provide some hope um on what's ahead
because
uh it we are as caitlyn alluded to
earlier there is still we are still in
the middle of a war with the pandemic
and
uh he will certainly be clear about that
uh but he also wants to give people a
sense of
what's possible and what's ahead and
what we can look ahead to
uh once uh more and more people in the
country are vaccinated
go ahead so the president has visited
wisconsin and michigan he's going to
visit pennsylvania georgia
has there been a special emphasis on him
visiting presidential battleground
states
in the early days of his presidency no
he did win a lot of states
so i will say that um uh he you will see
him uh
visit red state states he did not win of
course
blue states and states he did not visit
during the campaign
as well um so that is certainly part of
his uh
desire and interest and commitment and
something we've also talked about
quite a bit because he is committed to
governing for all of the american people
not just people in blue states or swing
states or purple states or whatever
color you want to call them and that is
something he has a great interest in
doing and
you know even when he was he also
visited texas which is certainly
not not yet a blue state but um but when
he was there he traveled around the
state with governor abbott because his
view is that when we're addressing
crises whether it's a weather crisis or
covid or
the economic downturn that uh you know
he's going to govern for all for all
americans and work with
people of both parties okay that's just
the unrelated question
so the relief bill includes subsidies
for the healthcare exchanges
and covert coverage president during the
campaign talked about also implementing
a universal public option lowering the
medicare age to 60.
does he still plan to pursue those
policy initiatives and we
expected to hear more on that from him
yes
i mean we're only on day 50. we've got a
lot more time to go here
um buckle up uh yes he is uh of course
this was
his number one priority was getting this
american rescue plan
passed today is a very big day here in
the white house
um significant moment for the american
people
of course but he remains committed to
and interested in
pushing forward with the rest of his
agenda and the commitments he made when
he ran for president
uh over the course of the last two years
go ahead
thank you last june then candidate biden
said looking ahead in the first
100 days of my presidency i've committed
to creating a national police oversight
commission
is that something that he still intends
to establish within the first 100 days
he does we have 50 days left look at all
we've accomplished in 50 days
we have much more to much more to happen
in the next 50.
i don't have a timeline for you uh you
know this of course because when he came
in he knew
that taking steps to uh get um
you know addressing the pandemic under
control
to get relief out to the american people
had to be what he spent his time doing
but of course there's a lot he wants to
do to address the
four crises as he's defined them that
are facing the country and racial
inequality is certainly one of them uh
he talked about as you mentioned the
police commission uh when he was running
and
certainly there's a lot more uh that he
would like to get done from his agenda
can i just ask one more question about
the american rescue plan yeah i'm
following up on caitlyn's question
you've said that some of the money is
starting to go out as soon as this
weekend so why has the white house
not yet announced the person overseeing
the implementation of the bill and when
can we expect that announcement and then
once that person is appointed
how will that person be working with the
various inspectors general of the
agencies
and the pandemic responsible
accountability committee to ensure
adequate oversight
well it doesn't you know the president
believes it's a model
looking back at the recovery act where
having a person who can pull
all the levers of of government and uh
engage with mayors and
and you know lead city leaders and
community leaders is
an effective means of ensuring that
implementation is
efficient um moving forward uh i only
told you about the
one person yesterday who is going to
oversee this
so while i don't have personnel
announcements for you today it's also
clear that that is
not delaying our implementation i mean
the treasury department the irs will
still be the ones who are implementing
the
uh direct the direct checks or the
direct deposits which is what the
majority of people will get
and of course the department of
education will still be the ones
overseeing and working with school
districts
in order to get funding out to reopen
schools none of that is changing we're
just talking about a person to be the
uh coordinator but it doesn't delay the
implementation of the bill and
of course it's a priority to him and why
he wants to have somebody
uh in that position will that person be
working with the inspectors general and
the various agencies though to make sure
that the money is going out as smoothly
as possible that there's no
i mean i know that a lot of watchdog
groups raised ever raised
issues with how the money was dispersed
under agencies in the trump
administration so will the person
overseeing implementation be looking at
that to make sure that well reducing
waste fraud and abuse and preventing it
is certainly priority for the president
uh he's already taken steps to address
that in this
uh in the last 50 days and certainly
when he was overseeing the recovery act
that was a priority for him
so i'm certain that as we look to
implementation that will continue to be
a focus of his as well
go ahead in the back yeah the question
about the first meeting today at the u.s
israel strategic room
how important is it to president biden
that the
u.s strategy on iran he coordinated with
israel given the fact that
the israeli leader benjamin netanyahu
doesn't like the deal has been very
vocal about it
uh we feel that um you noticed you noted
a strategy or a meeting today i should
say that
many here may not be aware of i can
share more details on that but
um it's vital to um the president to the
administration that
um as we are looking ahead to uh
approaching diplomacy
uh and moving toward um you know
a diplomatic track to preventing iran
from acquiring a
a nuclear weapon that israel is a will
be a continued partner
will be regularly briefed and that was
true
when the jcpoa was being negotiated and
put into place to begin with and
certainly would be
the case if this diplomatic track moves
forward so are you trying to kind of
avoid some of the public acrimony
that was evidenced when joe biden was
vice president
it's very clear that benjamin netanyahu
doesn't like this deal
well it was clear for some time and then
once it was in place i think
many countries in the region were happy
to have the um
direct visibility into what iran was
uh doing uh to have inspectors on the
ground and
certainly were very familiar with the
opposition as the bill is being
negotiated and we
can will continue to work with and
directly engage with israel if this if
there's a diplomatic path forward and
even without that
they're an important partner israel is
um but
i i would say there it quieted a bit
once that once once there was a
recognition
of um the benefit of visibility on the
ground and we don't have that now and we
haven't had it since the trump
administration pulled out of the deal
just just to follow up though
how concerned is it is president biden
of statements coming out of israel for
example from the head of the idf
who so the military option is still on
the table that he thinks it's a bad idea
to to get back to this deal i mean
is the united states worried that the
relationship with israel could
draw the united states into some sort of
armed conflict with iran
well we've been clear that we feel the
best path forward
is a diplomatic path and that's why we
are working with our eu
european partners to see what is
possible
along that front uh we also believe that
it's an opportunity to um expand
on the jcpoa and and work to address
additional concerns we have in the
region but of course we're not we're
very familiar with
uh the concerns israel has expressed and
that's one of the reasons we engage with
them so closely
around this and many other issues and
just very quickly the last question
obviously there are imminent elections
in israel as well as iran
is the sort of strategy right now to
kind of wait till the outcome of those
elections and know who you're dealing
with moving forward
no i would say the strategy is to
work in close coordination with our
european partners who will
continue to be key partners as part of
the p5 plus one as is russia and china
uh should there be a diplomatic and
we're hopeful there's a diplomatic path
forward
uh and certainly we are you know we view
this as part of the diplomatic process
waiting to see what the back and forth
about the engagement
will be but we're not looking to delay
the diplomatic process we are
um you know looking to hear back from
the iranians and work closely with our
europeans on the process
go ahead congressman john yarmuth
seemed to think the other day that the
president's budget might not be coming
until may
when when does the president plan to
release his 2022
budget blueprint and when he does will
he submit a plan
that that balances in a 10-year window
i don't have any predictions for you on
the timeline of the budget as we talked
about a bit during the transition uh
because of some of the intransigence of
political appointees during the
transition period we
already anticipated it would be delayed
back in december and january
obviously the fact that we don't have a
confirmed omb director in place
um doesn't help expedite that timeline
but so we knew it would be delayed but i
don't have a specific timeline for you
or a frame of what it will look like
does the president support congressional
democrats push to restore earmarking
is that a way to sort of foster
bipartisanship after this 1.9 trillion
package that didn't get any republican
support well we don't have a package yet
that we're talking about um that we are
working through with congress
obviously the president's uh spent 36
years in the senate and he uh
is quite familiar with the role of
earmarks but i don't
when we have a package to announce and
we're talking about the legislative
strategy we can probably talk about it
more
i mean because democrats are making the
case that this will
you know it's a way to get republicans
to support spending bills things along
those lines is that
the white house's view is is earmarking
a
potential path to sort of break some of
this gridlock
we just don't have a legislative package
we're even talking about here so when we
do
we can have a discussion about what the
legislative strategy is but we're not at
that point we
just signed into law the president just
signed into law today a 1.9 trillion
dollar
package that he is looking forward to
implementing that's our focus
and in the coming weeks we'll have more
to say what's next and then we can have
a
discussion about how we're going to get
that package through on the 1400s
sorry go ahead you're fine on the 1400
checks consumer
advocates are raising concerns that
private debt collectors might be able to
intercept part of it because apparently
language
protected that in the last round of 600
checks
but because of the budget reconciliation
process
senators had to cut that out with the
president's support
stand-alone legislation i think senator
wyden says he's going to be working on
that
and how does the president expect to get
stand-alone legislation
to take care of that issue and how does
the president expect to get bipartisan
support
for sort of these provisions technical
corrections like these that
pop up you know on every major bill like
this
i'm not sure if there are technical
corrections needed i'd have to talk to
the department of treasury about that i
mean in terms of the
checks uh 90 of them about will go via
direct deposit
to people's bank accounts that they have
because of people paying taxes
um if there are other additional
components that require that i'm happy
to have that discussion with them and
see if they
think there's technical changes needed
and if those technical changes
require congress which i'm not i'm not
sure they would or wouldn't at this
point
go ahead in the back thank you i have a
i have a couple of questions
last week president biden in his virtual
interaction with
nasa scientist dr mohan said that
india people of indian descent are
taking over the country then
clarify that what did he meant by that
because there have been some criticism
by his opponents on his remarks well i
would first say that uh the president
was
just recognizing and honoring and
valuing or this was his intention
uh the incredible contribution of indian
americans to
uh science uh he was speaking to a
an indian-american woman who is of
course a scientist and
uh and an important part of the nasa
team
and he also was of course recognizing
the incredible contribution of his own
vice president uh and he just believes
that um
it was a reflection of his belief that
indian americans uh
have a make a great contribution to the
fabric of society whether it's
science or education or the government
and that was what he was trying to
convey a number of indian americans who
came to this country as a legal
immigrants and want to make this as a
home
they feel that this administration is
not much focused
on resolving the issues related to legal
immigrants
rather than they're more focused on
illegal immigrants what you have to say
on that
i would say they we should um you should
write an article
about how uh the president's immigration
bill uh proposes uh
a number of uh fixes or changes in the
legal and legislative system to ensure
um
that those issues are addressed and
we're eager to move that forward with
members of both parties 50th day
and tomorrow president is addressing the
quad leaders summit a few days later
uh secretary state and nsa are having
their bilateral meetings
in tankaris and kara on china
after 50 days what are your major ask
from china what do you want
china to do so that to improve the
relationship that the united states has
with president
well i would expect obviously this this
meeting uh next week
we felt it was important to have it on
u.s soil we certainly anticipate that
national security adviser jake sullivan
and secretary of state tony blinken will
be discussing both the challenges we've
had
and not holding back on issues and
concerns we have
we have with the behavior of uh chinese
leadership uh whether it's on
uh taiwan uh or uh recent
um you know efforts to um push back
democracy in hong kong or
on concerns we have about
the economic relationship so they will
certainly raise those issues and the
lack of transparency as it relates to
covet human rights abuses as well
but they'll also talk about uh areas of
opportunity and ways we can work
together we certainly will not they will
not be holding back in the conversation
but
uh they wanted to you know it's an
important moment next week to
engage directly and and in person and uh
we're
i know they're looking forward to it
we'll have a robust readout i'm sure
when that meeting concludes
the foreign journalists colleague of
mine wouldn't be present here has sent
me a question for you
the international olympics committee
today announced that china will provide
vaccination for athletes
teams and attendees of the tokyo olympic
games
what is the response to uh what is your
response to ioc's announcement
does the administration recommend the
u.s at least attendees get vaccination
from the chinese
i i would have to i would send you to
the internet uh the u.s olympic
committee
uh we of course are working to ensure
that uh the american people are
have access to vaccines we'll have
enough to vaccine vaccinate i should say
all american adults by the end of may
certainly that includes olympic athletes
but i would refer you to them on their
plans for vaccinating athletes
go ahead thanks jen a couple on talks we
haven't touched on yet
but politico ran a poll yesterday i'm
not sure if you saw it
finding that 53 percent of americans
think that there should be a ban
on transgender athletes competing in
women's sports included in that
were 40 of democratic respondents who
agreed
that there should be a ban and 49 of
independence
obviously the president is committed to
advancing lgbtq
rights but looking at this through his
call for unity lens
do you think these opinions are coming
more from a place i'm trying to protect
women's rights or equality and that
these just flat bigoted opinions
that president shouldn't acknowledge at
this point
the opinions in the poll well people who
voice support for banning transgender
athletes i did not conduct the poll
nor was i part of the polling committee
that had conversations with people uh
what i can convey to you
is that the president believes
regardless of this poll in politico did
you say politico i guess
i didn't see the poll or the article but
uh but
i didn't read playbook um but i um but i
the president believes that transgender
rights are human rights that
uh that kids uh should not be
discriminated against and should be able
to play sports and that continues to be
his belief and that hasn't changed but
i'm not going to
guess or attribute motive to the people
who responded to that poll or any poll
actually
and then on the house's passage of these
gun violence legislation bills
uh today has that has the white house
been actively courting
uh republican senators to to vote yay
for this
obviously from a numbers standpoint it's
gonna be a lot harder to pass there than
in the house
and if not does the president believe it
can pass the senate
or those two bills can pass the senate
in their current iterations
well first you know the president is
someone who is personally committed to
addressing
gun violence and working to put in place
gun safety measures he's called on
congress to act he supports congress
acting
he's looking forward to working with
them to advance priorities
including repealing gun manufacturers
liability shield
of course these pieces of legislation
were regarding background checks and he
certainly supports
uh actions uh by the house to pass those
bills and
i expect he will look for opportunities
to be engaged
and advocate for why uh these are
not political issues these are common
sense uh efforts to
uh keep our children safe keep our
country safe and
um you know ensure that we are um you
know reducing gun violence in the
country
just one follow-up on the quad summit
tomorrow does the president plan on
speaking with our allies about ways we
can force china to stop
the genocide it's committed against the
weaker muslims in xinjiang
in that summit tomorrow well i know that
uh addressing uh the
genocide um uh against weaker muslims is
something that will be a topic of
discussion with the chinese directly
next week uh
but certainly this conversation uh
tomorrow and we're hoping i've invited
national security adviser jake sullivan
to come uh and give you a readout of
that meeting i know there's a lot of
interest in the quad
summit tomorrow um but we expect the
conversation to be
about a range of global issues uh it is
not focused on china of course
china is a topic on the minds of many
leaders and countries but
we expect they will talk about the
climate crisis about economic
cooperation about addressing kovid
a range of issues and discussions and um
you know certainly the position of the
united states is that
uh what is happening uh is genocide and
we
um you know we'll look for opportunities
to work with
other partners on uh putting additional
pressure on the chinese but
we will also raise it directly and it
will be a topic of discussion next week
thanks everyone thank you
you